- [Instructor] What
are all positive values
of p such that the series converges?
So let's see.
We have the sum from n equals one
to infinity of negative one to the n
plus one, times p over six to the n.
So there's a couple of things
that might jump out at you.
This negative one to the n plus one,
as n goes from one to two to three,
this is just going to
alternate between positive one,
negative one, positive one, negative one.
So we're gonna have alternating signs.
That might be a little bit
of a clue of what's going on,
and actually, let's just write it out.
This is going to be,
see when n equals one,
this is going to be to the second power,
so it's gonna be positive one.
So it's gonna be p over
six, and when n is two,
this is gonna be to the third power,
so it's gonna be minus p over six squared,
then plus p over six to the third power.
And I could even write to the
first power right over here.
Then minus p over six to the fourth power,
and we're gonna just
keep going plus, minus,
on and on and on and on forever.
This is clearly, this is a
classic alternating series
right over here, and we could actually
apply our alternating series test.
And our alternating series test tells us
that if this part of our expression,
the part that is not alternating in sign,
I guess you could say, if this part
of the expression is
monotonically decreasing,
which is just a fancy way of saying that
each successive term is less
than the term before it,
and if we also know that the limit of this
as n approaches infinity, that
also has to be equal to zero.
So the limit as n approaches infinity
of p over six to the nth power
also has to be equal to zero.
Under what conditions is
that going to be true?
Well, to meet either
one of those conditions,
p over six has to less than one.
If p over six was equal to one,
if, for example, p was six, well then
we wouldn't be monotonically decreasing.
Every term here would just be one.
It would be one to the one,
one squared, on and on and on.
And if p is greater than
six, well, then every time
we multiply by p over six again,
we would get a larger
number over and over again,
and the limit for sure
would not be equal to zero.
We could say p over six
needs to be less than one,
and so multiply both sides by six
and you get p needs to be less than six.
And they told us, for what are
all the positive values of p?
So we also know that p has
to be greater than zero.
P is greater than zero and less than six,
which is that choice right over here.
Once again, we're not gonna
say less than or equal to six
because if p was equal to six, this term
is gonna be one to the
n, and so we're just
gonna have, this would be one.
It would be one minus one plus one,
on and on and on and on forever.
So definitely like that first choice.